In this problem, a waste mixture with
the following principal organic
hazardous constituents or PC's is
incinerated and all chlorine atoms are
converted to HCl.
Find the total HCl flow rate in kilog
generated during incineration prior to
control.
So here we are given three different
PCs in our waste feed. One, two
dchloroeththane,
chloromthane
and benzene.
Our objective is to figure out how much
HCl is present from the incineration
process.
So for step one, let's decide which
compounds actually matter.
So let's look at the atomic weights that
we can find in the reference manual. The
three that we need are C, H, and CL
since these are present to some extent
in each of the parts of the table.
So C is going to be 12 g per mole. H is
going to be 1 and CL is going to be
35.45.
So we can calculate the molecular
weights now for each of the feed items
that contributes to HCl.
This would rule out benzene from the
rest of the problem since there is no CL
in that waste feed.
Let's fill in the rest in the existing
table below.
So we have 12 g per mole time 2 C's
plus
1 g per mole of H
times four of those plus
35.45 45 g per mole*
2 for CL
and that is going to come out to 98.9
g per mole.
Down here we have 12 * 1
+
1 * 3. Sorry about the parentheses being
inconsistent. plus 35.45
and that's going to be equal to
50.45.
And then we don't need to calculate the
last one. Now for step two
and three, we can convert the feed rates
into moles per hour. So for step two,
let's convert the feed to grams hour.
So, we're already given it in kilograms.
So, let's just multiply by a th00and.
You could skip writing this out on the
exam if you need to save time.
And since we have grams per mole and
grams per hour, we can now divide
column two here
by column 1.5
and
calculate our feed
in moles per hour.
So, 180,000
g per hour
divided by
98.9
g per mole.
gives us just about
moles per hour.
And doing this again for
chloromthane we will get about
4357.
Now for step four,
we're going to convert the moles of each
compound into moles of chlorine atoms.
So if we take dchloroethane,
which is C2
H4
CL2,
we can see that there are two HCl moles
present of chlorine atoms.
Similarly for C H3
CL
we could create one
for benzene C6 H6. We already stated
there is no Cl component here. So we're
not going to have any.
So for this next step, we are going to
multiply the moles of chlorine atoms
available to us by the feed mole.
So this will be 1819
mole hour* 2 to give us 36 38
mole hour.
And then
obviously 4357
* 1 remains
mole hour. So if we sum these together
we will have just about 7995
mole hour. So for step five we'll
convert the moles of HCl to a mass in
kilog. So all we have to do here is
multiply by the weight of our HCl, which
we didn't calculate. So let's just do
that right here
and say
1 for H plus
35.45
for Cl to give us 36.45
g per mole.
So times 36.45
g per mole here. This would give us just
about
g per hour.
And obviously if we divide back
by a th00and we would get 291.5
kilogram
per hour
which would lead us over here to number
three being the closest answer.
So,
this problem has a few more steps than
some of the others on this channel, but
all it is is unit conversions from kilog
to moles hour for the PHC's,
then converting back to kg hour to find
the units for HCl.
And one other quick conceptual note,
although benzene in this problem doesn't
supply chlorine, the H and HCls
can come from water vapor or other
hydrocarbons in an incinerator's flame.
So there could be chlorinated compounds
without hydrogen on the exam that they
give you that would still produce HCl
since there's hydrogen available during
the combustion. So just something they
might do to try to trick you. And that's
it.